j'avais une idée préconçue une pareille
de la situation de la lhjmq depuis que
je suis arrivé ici j'ai eu une autre
pays complètement différent
l'effervescence la construction quand je
crois que énormément d'argent à faire
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya énormément d'activités
normativité c'est peut-être naître une
ignorance de caisse qui est vraiment
ligne qui fait qu'on hésite on pense
encore que cet arc est aussi loin de là
sont très évolué jamais j'aurais pas
ainsi qu on est et reste stable qui
avait autant d'investissements qui se
faisait si les buildings l'avez vu comme
moi comment tu es ce que ça pose comme
des champignons et c'est de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent du pays pour juste du
gouvernement mais des richesses internes
du pays qui investissent dans leur pays
la grosseur de l'époque de la population
de sa pauvreté est un désavantage
avec l'informatisation et toutes les
nouvelles technologies
ce n'est plus un désavantage c'est une
force
d'amener des gens a produit sur un
milliard trois cents millions
il ya beaucoup nos têtes
très très intelligente et sur terrain
qui viennent développer des choses
exceptionnelles et coûte pas cher et qui
coûte moins chère juste le téléphone 90%
de la population
sosa au téléphone les transactions
bancaires si tout changer si cette
réforme est c'est tout informatique
directement sur le téléphone
alors les problèmes de liquidités
d'argenço film qu'un camion qu'ils
prenaient
dix-huit jours à traverser l'inde
au programme 3 à 4 jours d'ici cinq ans
ça va faire changer le transport
incroyable et juste de visiter une
entreprise qui fait des motos et
produisent au globe 7 millions de motos
par année et s'est vendue à la vanille
est juste leurs produits même pas vendu
à l'externe et vendu que localement
l'inde est un pays qui selon - est
capable de se suffire et autosuffisant
économique
c'est sûr qu'ils dépendent de certaines
choses au point de vue énergétique et
tout le monde en dépend avec un milliard
pour 5 millions on ne peut pas mettre de
côté ce pays là
[Musique]